wir sind in alanya und zwar waren wir am
und hier sind wir auf seiner katzen
auffangstation beim er alaba und zwar
macht es schon seit sieben jahren
ehrenamtlich
jeden tag kommt sie her und kümmert sich
um die katzen ihren die werden ja
ausgesetzt jetzt erzählte gerade das ist
ja gerade ein richtiger regen und es
eigentlich eine seltenheit weil es hier
eigentlich so gut wie nie regnet jetzt
haben gestern wieder weise babykatzen
ausgesetzt und sie findet eigentlich
auch nur ganz schnell und ganz schnell
und exakt dieselbe weg an die bekannten
aussetzen nicht immer klappt am kopf 12
vorbeigehen
radikal macht es ehrenamtlich und
gemeint hier sammelte die ganzen platz
neun
wir unterstützen jetzt auch gleich in
mehreren ab land mit ein bisschen geld
natürlich wäre es echt toll ich was ihr
hier macht und um die katzen müsste hier
gekümmert ist echt der wahnsinn
addieren
einem
arzt vor
dass jeden tag zum arzt gebracht und das
macht sie wirklich selber mit ihrem
eigenen geld macht sie ehrenamtlich die
ganzen platzen und das ist wie gesagt in
alanya
wir sind da nicht mal die ist macht es
ganz ganz viel für katze ja aber jetzt
geht's um babykatzen
aber hier
so sehen sie aus oh mein gott so kriegt
kaum die augen auf
nicht die mama
dass ich die mutter
[Musik]
die haben die
tifosi sagt gerade macht ja jeden tag
sauber und sind gerade das
wahrscheinlich ein restaurantbetreiber
die katzen hergebracht hat mit seiner
kiste und die haben einfach die ganze
kiste mit hopfen babys ausgeleert hier
rein und sauber gemacht
wir haben jetzt schon eine mitgenommen
und wie gesagt und die macht das
ehrenamtlich ist so genial was die frau
die am 8
mit ihr werden
und zwar da wird die gruppe geben aus
belgien die unterstützen das ganz ganz
stark und sagt ihr geld wird dafür nicht
ausreichen und die punkte katzen waren
zum zum arzt nie ball hin und die gruppe
in belgien unterstützt sie die
unterstützten sie jetzt auch hier im
kreis da ich selber zwei katzen habe
weiß ich wie heftig es ist die kleine
maus
guck mal hier
ich liebt katzen so art keine angst
auch ein kleiner racker ist durch kleine
racker
oh mein gott ist das ziel
hallo
katzen sind so etwas wundervolles echt
wir haben selber zwei stück wir haben
letztes jahr selbst eine katze hausmüll
gebot nach hause gebracht
ja auf jeden fall waren sie was sie hier
machen immer voll süßer
folter hamburger ich weiß die kids
finden ist auch gerne alle mitnehmen das
ging leider nicht um eine putzfrau
alleine
und da wurden sie in der kiste in der
kiste wurden sie von dem onkel
restaurant abgeliefert und einfach hier
hingestellt aber wenigstens haben sie
das gemacht und die katzen nicht getötet
irgendwas also es ist in der türkei auch
verboten
seine mutter wieder auf ihre babys
aufpassen
okay sie passt jetzt aufgebaut internets
passt es nicht runterfallen und das sind
nicht wehtun man sieht doch die zitzen
das ist auch was die mutter ist und wie
gesagt es ist da hat die leute haben
sehr wenig geld
um viele machen was also die die
großteil der bevölkerung führen und sich
um die um die katzen und tiere die
türkei hat auch ein ganz krass des
tierschutz gesetz erlassen ich glaub
auch wenn man tiere irgendwie sinnlos
umbringt
damit sinnlos umbringt stärkt auch zehn
jahre haft darauf aber trotzdem viel zu
wenig und das problem
ist nicht die regierung des problems
aufgerufen die meisten menschen weil sie
die katzen und die uni nicht kastrieren
also die schuldfrage warum sowas ist ja
es sind nicht gibt es mehrere schuldige
nicht nur wie gesagt die regierung
sondern auch die menschen die einfach
hier sorglos katzen einfach aussetzen
passiert bei uns in deutschland auf ganz
schlimm und da kommt ein richtig leben
aber selber tiere hat und mein schatz
ich würde ich sogar mitten hinein was
ich mit meinem augen du hast doch
irgendwas
und du musst
oh mann
die seele
wird
je mehr klären
warum ist die zunge dauernd draußen das
team aus was ist mit deiner zu gehen
damit nicht reichen
und je was ich nicht dazu noch müssen
uns wieder und außen
macht die zunehmend wieder reinkommt
auch diesmal wieder rein
ja also wenn ihr wenn ihr im urlaub
kommt nach alanya und die kommen in
diesem park hier nach alanya und ist der
kitt parkt dann unterstützt die frau
einfach es steckt etwas zu
die macht es da nicht echt cool
heimatstadt
wo ich lieb dich oh gott ich liebe dich
mein
schatz
mich wundert was ist das hier franzi
gerade
[Musik]
da müsste ich das ganze hat sie eine
ganz kleine kinder kostenlose
antibiotika bei
den solisten und wenn sie das nicht kann
sie auch antibiotika termin mit amine ok
multivitamin die eckdaten der damen mit
fehlern führen müsse augentropfen
gemacht
also wenn jemand ein pilz hat eine katze
pilz hat es ist schon so ein first aid
kit was ihr da hat sobald
also im ersten tag an ist da hat sie
hier und macht es
auch so
so also wie ich folgendes geschafft und
im hotel ist aber schon rentnerin und
schafft aber trotzdem soll ich könnte
das alles hier nicht machen und bezahlen
also vieles macht sie selber es wird
aber auch von aus belgien unterstützt
und von den menschen wieder
auffrischen
meine
okay da hat sie so passten das gibt es
dann den linken katzen so alle zwei tage
wie sie jetzt hier aber wirklich ich
habe das schon selber gesehen die
menschen hier also die privaten menschen
hier aber auch
regierungsorganisationen helfen den
tieren und
ich habe trotzdem traurig als die
menschen man viel zu sagen hier wird gar
nichts gemacht ist absolut falsch ist
kann immer mehr sein aber die machen das
echt gehören
das ist falsch
aber wie gesagt man kann immer mehr
machen für tiere aber das ist schon
krass aus die frau macht vor allem wenn
sie nebenher noch ein hotel arbeitet ist
noch bin ich nebenberuflich
so cool
die
nase und augen
über die zwei ärgern die
ach so sie kennzeichnet
mein gott jeden augen
ach
so also muss ich mir gerade erklärt die
schwarze katze und die weiße katze in
den jungs oder sich ein mädchen und das
mädchen das ich ziemlich gesundes
mädchen und sie wollte jetzt an das
mädchen ran aber ich möchte nicht
nur der bus voll cool erklärt dass
contras also das mädchen da drin was
gesagt wird von den zwei jungs ist dies
sehr sehr gesund und die zwei die wollen
möchten sich fortpflanzen mit ihr aber
die möchte nicht und deswegen
ja das bringt sachs taxi bringt man die
tat zu recht bei der jüngsten wollen
mich auf sie drauf und kinder zeugen ich
kenne auch mit katze sowie nicht aus
aber das ist schon wahnsinn ja aber die
frau kennt sich wirklich cool aus
ok also liebe grüße aus alanya
es war ich mit ihr was mache ich mit dir